although the sandin family seems kind of
neutral and doesn't participate in the
purge themselves if we read into the
subtext we can see how they really feel
the display of blue batisias is a sign
of support for the purge in the same way
that a pink ribbon is a sign of support
for the fight against breast cancer in
our world this light blue to cyan color
can be found
all over the sanden's house it's on
their curtains their kitchen their
furniture
their possessions and even their clothes
all of the neighbors who participate in
the purge also don this color
charlie however is fundamentally against
the purge and he is the only one not to
wear the color
even the interface of their security
system uses this color of blue
and this is the system that is supposed
to keep them safe and keep the homeless
out on the streets to be purged the
sandins do not initially have bad
intentions but it is because of the
purge that mr sandon is able to sell a
ton of security systems and become rich
10 years ago we could barely afford rent
now we're thinking about buying a boat
so the financial comfort caused by the
purge causes mr and mrs sandin to
unknowingly look past how bad it really
is the batisia blue color also becomes a
symbol of the political party behind the
purge the new founding fathers of
america or the nffa
in a television interview early on the
behavioral scientist dr peter binac also
wears this color as he explains how the
purge is effective claiming that it
creates a psychological stability by
allowing pent-up aggression to be
released however later sequels would
confirm that this data isn't accurate
and it's actually quite the opposite
so the batesia blue he is wearing is
likely a clue to the audience that this
man is an nffa plant spreading
misinformation for political reasons
i'll also explore how one of the
neighbors has ties to a high-ranking
nffa official so stick around to the end
of this video to hear about it
america 2022 unemployment is at one
percent
yeah it doesn't look like we're gonna
make that in real life welcome to things
you missed today i'm covering
the purge the dystopian not too distant
future horror story about a night each
year where all crime is legal for 12
continuous hours in the opening credits
we see the video feeds of the previous
nationwide purges that have taken place
for the past
six years leading up to this night the
story is just a small snapshot of one
family's experience in this messed up
version of society but its simplicity is
also what makes it great and it still
contains setups to the greater lore that
we'd become familiar with as the
franchise would expand
so let's lower the security doors and
take a deeper look into some of those
hidden details
[Music]
as james sandin returns home from work
he hears a guy on the radio explaining
his own plans for purge nights
pete from northern virginia what's your
purge plan i'm gonna hunt down my boss
a son of a has it coming the idea of an
employee going after his or her boss
would be explored in further detail in
the purge season one and i don't want to
already be going on this rant but uh
i'm already going on this rant it's so
annoying how the purge franchise is
titled if i say the purge
i could be referring to this original
movie the tv series called the purge or
the franchise as a whole but i can't say
the first purge because the fourth movie
is called the first purge i mean they
should have called the prequel the purge
experiment and they should have given
each season of the series a subtitle
like the purge homecoming and
the purge bloodstained saints or
something like that those are actually
pretty good we soon meet the sand and
kids
zoe is the bratty teen prep student with
a ton of accolades she's an excellent
writer
softball player and gymnast she even won
a marathon and is also an excellent
horseback rider her little brother is
very much the opposite he's more of a
science standout engineering his own
drone that he calls timmy i'm not sure
if this is an intentional toy story
reference but it is very similar to
sid's babyface creation so i'm gonna
count it
charlie also has some disturbing
drawings of the purge hidden in the
secret spot behind his closets these are
never explained so we're only left to
wonder if this seemingly innocent
character has a dark side i know the
idea about the kid who once lost a
parent in the purge has already been
done a couple times now but it would at
least be interesting to see where
charlie and zoe ended up they could just
get tommy wiseau to play charlie as an
adult
at dinner charlie tells about his day at
school
and in english i wrote a story about a
man whose love is so powerful
that it can kill people so it cuts out
his own heart
that is so sweet this story is kind of
similar to what happens to mr sanden in
the purge it is his love for his family
that fuels his motivation to give dante
up to the purgers so that they can be
safe but he realizes the error of his
ways which ultimately means sacrificing
his own life to save everyone else when
he locks down the house we can see the
security code 101
382 i was looking around online to see
if there might be any significance
behind that number
famousfix.com suggests that this equates
to the dates 10 13
1982 the date of ronald reagan's address
to the nation on the economy
i'm somewhat skeptical that this could
be the motivation but it's worth noting
that the purge is supposed to boost the
economy
crime is down the economy is flourishing
the family gets together for lockdown
when james notices this
hey look at this mr sabian and mr babaro
are going hunting that's daring
the name sabian is significant at the
time this was just kind of a throwaway
reference that director james demonico
like to put in his movies his 2005 film
assault on precinct 13 had a character
named dr
alex sabian and he wrote the screenplay
for the 1998 film the negotiator which
had a character named chris sabian these
were probably references to andrea
sabian who he's given a special thanks
to in the credits of the purge and the
purge election year but looking back on
this line now we can connect it to a
character who is part of the purge
experiment arlo sabian was the nfa chief
of staff who tried to manipulate the
results of the experiments by killing
people to make it look like it had been
a success
it's hard to say whether or not this
could actually be him but it could
definitely be a relative as they both
obviously support the nffa mr sandon
would spend the beginning of the evening
finishing up some paperwork but another
secret can be found on the tv
that he has playing in the background
[Music]
zoe goes back to her room where she
discovers that her boyfriend henry never
left the house that afternoon i noticed
that her pillow has some text on it that
reads lights out
this isn't a reference to the movie
lights out but it could be a
foreshadowing of the moments that the
power gets cut
as james finishes up his work from that
day listen to the tv in the
feeds from around background country and
discussing the purge with criminologist
tommy agard
tommy agard is also a significant name
it's a reference to the first assistant
editor and visual effects editor one of
the news broadcasts features purge
coverage of staten island now director
james demonico
is kind of obsessed with staten island
his first movie was originally titled
staten island before the title was
changed to little new york he also wrote
and produced the first purge which was
set on staten island and he's working on
a new movie called once upon a time in
staten island
i told you he's obsessed charlie feels
bad when he sees a homeless man who we
later find out to be named dante bishop
begging for help on the streets and
temporarily disarms the security system
to let him inside
then right as that happens henry attacks
mr sanden who had been against henry's
relationship with his daughter
this allows dante to escape into the
house mr sandin fires back at henry
which proves to be a fatal reaction a
group of purgers outside
threaten to tear down the door if they
don't deliver dante so mr sandon goes to
look for him and in the hall he comes
across his family photos covered in
blood a symbol of his worst case
scenario for purge knight
eventually he finds dante but he's taken
zoey as a hostage and the scene is part
of what makes this purge movie the best
there are lots of scenes in the other
movies where suspense is artificially
created because a purger holding someone
at gunpoint just doesn't pull the
trigger when they should
sometimes to a ridiculous extent this
scene however has a reason for it if
dante kills zoe
there's no reason for james and mary not
to jump him and give him to the purgers
mrs sandin sneaks up behind him but she
won't shoot him either because if they
can't turn dante over to the purgers
alive then they'll break into the house
and release the beast on the family
instead
mr sanden has to make a moral decision
does he kill a possibly innocent man to
guarantee his own family's safety
or take his chances against them perhaps
putting everyone's life in danger
ultimately
he ends up feeling empathy for dante
perhaps due to him being able to feel
sympathy for his situation because he
was poor
just 10 years ago james doesn't make it
but his decision still ends up saving
his family because dante returns the
favor by protecting them when the
neighbors turn against them later that
night
during the end credits we learned that
this was supposedly the most successful
purge according to the nffa who just
want to see a lot of violence and weapon
sales
the new founding fathers have released
an early statement saying this was the
most successful purge yet
this is a running theme in the franchise
it seems like each purge is always more
violence than the last
the next purge would take place one year
later and feature many more families
struggling to stay alive during the
annual holiday
so click that video on the left and join
me in the next episode of things you
missed where i'll be covering the purge
anarchy and if you love horror remember
to subscribe to cz's world for new
horrors every week ring the death bell
for
notifications and i'll see you in the
next one assuming
we both survive and like the purge i do
recommend you stay home
but if you have to go out wear a mask